[Music]
hey you guys
happy whatever the [ __ ] today is tuesday
yes we're sitting here we're sitting
here [ __ ] talking about what it is
we're gonna make after the show it's
like one friday yeah
or something
look this is a good movie whoever
recommended this who recommended this i
can't remember now was it was it you
danny rowling that you might have
recommended but yeah i the weird thing
about it is that
um
i had seen this before yeah because when
we first started watching it i was like
oh yeah this looks really familiar i
think i watched it because we haven't
done a show about the smurl haunting
have we no i don't think so i don't
think we have let me know how to do one
we very well might have yeah but so i
must have watched it when i was writing
about this like for my book i didn't so
i watched this a couple yeah so i
watched this a couple years back i think
cause some of it but i'd forgotten a lot
of it i kind of like remembered the
details of the case it's a made for tv
flick it's free on youtube it's worth
watching it's it's like uh
it's like a good episode of uh the
haunting without the narrator and kind
of it could tell they tried to kind of
do it a little bit like amityville
yeah it's a low budget flick but it's
it's well done
with a low budget made for tv 90s movie
but uh it's very linear very like easy
to understand
movie and um effective
you know what i mean it tells you about
the case and uh is it
scary kind of you know i mean it has
some creepy [ __ ] it's creepy and the
thing about it is that i think and i was
watching a couple other people's reviews
of this now danny rowling said too bad
there's not a physical copy of this film
to buy yeah it seems like there was a
dvd but it's not available weirdly
though i watched a review of this
earlier by um i think i guess it was a
british guy
and he had a dvd of it so i don't know
if it was it looked new i don't know if
it was old or whatever but i don't
i saw it on uh you know they it comes up
on amazon and it says there's a dvd but
it says unavailable and then it comes up
on prime video but then it also says
that's unavailable too you can watch it
for free on youtube but i don't know why
this seems like kind of obscure like i
found a couple other horror channels
that had covered it because a lot of
people really do seem to like this like
as tv horror movies this is actually
like a pretty good one and i feel like
it's like got like slightly more
uh recognition because like one guy was
saying he considered it he considers it
part of the conjuring universe because
it's yeah
ed and lorraine warren even though
obviously it's not
big budget and it's not like the same
people playing the warrens yeah but it's
an effective movie but yeah yeah i mean
it's very well done like for the for the
low budget that it had and it had like a
really a lot of really good act like
recognizable actors in it yeah you know
what i mean which is kind of crazy i
liked it it was almost kind of like uh
you could tell that they were trying to
do it along the lines of uh of
amityville
yeah and this is before the haunting
series
and it feels a lot like the haunting
series but like i said without the
narration
yeah this is essentially like maybe a
slightly slightly higher budget like
version of a haunting yeah even with
with actors that you recognize yeah even
though the haunting came from the
digital error the digital era and just
the way the haunting looked and the
special effects i would say probably
were better
but it didn't matter you just watched
the movie and it's it's uh it kind of
draws you into it because it's
you know it's claiming to be a real case
and
watching it it did it did kind of feel
like it was a real case you know i
haven't been involved in one myself
just the way the characters acted i was
like yeah that that's kind of like the
way we kind of were when we saw [ __ ]
like that
but
so it's credible it's fun and i think
the credibility of it kind of lends to
the creepiness
but it's got like some cheesy elements
it does they all do but that's okay i
mean like i said it's 1991 for crazy
it's a tv movie right when hollywood and
tv people get involved they're gonna
have to have that [ __ ] go over the top
and they went well what are we gonna do
for the big ending you know
and it has it has like two big endings
one after the other actually i guess you
could say but it's good it's good it's
good movie i like it i mean it's based
on the book that the smurl family wrote
with the warrens
so it's kind of like following yeah what
the smurls i think we did i think we did
this maybe we did because like i said i
know that i watched this movie for a
reason yeah so it was either because we
did a show about it and i was doing it
for research purposes or
i watched it when i was writing about
the case for my book which is also for
people that follow the show more about
know more about the show than we do well
because we've done so many that we get
we then i lose track well and the thing
about it too is that especially with the
paranormal cases like i wrote about a
lot of cases so a lot of times i'm like
wait did i just write about that
or did we do a show about it as well
right and then the same thing too
happened when i started writing like my
faceless villain books because i was
like oh well did i just write about that
murder case or did we do a show right i
get confused too and a lot of them are
saying confused yeah a lot of them kind
of have are a little bit samey sometimes
but if we haven't done this one then
drop it in the comment section and we'll
do we'll do a show on it yeah i think we
did a show on it but i don't know we'll
see zach said i think this movie was
good enough sally kirkland wanted emmy
for it no she was actually nominated for
a golden globe though but she didn't win
but yeah she was nominated for a golden
globe so sally kirkland i recognized
pretty much every actor in this yeah
even one of the little kids like one of
the little girls i'm pretty sure that
was the same little girl that was in the
monster squad if i'm not mistaken but
yeah like sally kirkland was in this who
was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff i didn't know
this but i looked her up earlier just
because i was curious um she was
actually like a big member of uh andy
warhol's factory like back in the day
and she was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff she
was in two evil eyes that uh dario
argento slash george romero zach liked
this he's jfk zach thought this was a
cool movie he died laughing at the part
where the neighbors were outside the
house to listen to the stockholder yeah
yeah i'd ask her yet what the [ __ ] is
going on in there yeah all
i like horrible screams i thought that
was like even though i recognized those
as like stock you know audio library
screams i was just like i still thought
that was like pretty creepy
i mean we were like making jokes about
it but
not as much it's not the cheesiest thing
i've ever seen it's actually some of it
was like really creepy some of the
creepiest [ __ ] i thought was some of the
stuff that didn't even have special
effects like the part where like the
part where she's um going down in the
basement like to do her laundry or
whatever and she hears what she thinks
is her mother-in-law like calling her
name
over and over like in that real like
weird flat tone and then it's like right
by her ear and stuff like that that was
actually like kind of spooky yeah and
the worst she hears like the water
running in the tub and then she goes up
there and there's nothing there it's
like so little [ __ ] like that i thought
was kind of creepier than
i mean she does see like apparitions and
then like it kind of goes crazy later
where she just gets she levitates out of
bed and then like she gets thrown around
the room yeah like danny says this movie
is simple yet effective it is it is
um now the only thing okay the only
thing i'm going to dang it for is if you
don't know the smurl case had some uh
rapey ass goes right yeah so um so
there's one scene where jack smirl
gets uh sexually assaulted by a female
ghost demon whatever [ __ ] or something
that looks like that and this the scene
is like she kind of looks like a normal
she throws him across the room first
like into a chair which is kind of
hilarious but then like she she like
straddles him and starts doing her thing
and she looks like
a regular girl at first just like a
little bit like her teeth are kind of
[ __ ] up and she looks like a little
bit crazy but then like it starts
flashing to
a man in a way like essentially like a
man
like a big dude like so it's supposed to
be this scary like he's supposed to look
like a hag i guess or something like
that and so that's like kind of funny so
i kind of wish they hadn't done that
so i think it's what he thought though
yeah i was like this i liked it i
thought it was [ __ ] hilarious it was
well it was hilarious because probably
like not
well
i thought it was hilarious because
[ __ ] like yeah i'd be resisting that
[ __ ] too
big fat man and a wig [ __ ] trying to
[ __ ] you yeah i was [ __ ] laughing
like a big fat ghost man yeah yeah yeah
it was like it was like a gray like a
witch wig or a
or something
it didn't matter it was it was it was
like a like yeah i didn't really say it
was a succubus that's essentially
succubus yeah it was moon zombie with a
[ __ ] another another 200 pounds of
fat on her
[ __ ] big old fake and sherry moon's on
me yeah sherry moon zombie with [ __ ]
200 pounds on her in a [ __ ] wig and
[ __ ] yeah
after her sex change
well see the thing about it though is
that of course like the real case i knew
like a little bit i can't remember like
all the exact details but i think they
left a few things out of the movie
because i think that not only
they left in like him getting sexually
assaulted by the demon but apparently
some of the other family members were as
well i think the only time that they
kind of hinted at that was when um
janet was in bed and she like the guy
was like grabbing her
like thigh like you couldn't see
anything you could just see like finger
marks and so they kind of hinted that
there was like a hand coming up thing
but they didn't like show and i think
some of the girls were too
another thing they left out was that
they said that it threw their dog
against the wall like several times and
i don't think the family in the movie
didn't have a dog did they
not that i remember yeah so maybe they
were just like yeah we're
maybe they were like me and they were
just like we can [ __ ] up all the people
we're not we're just not involving a dog
in this situation we're not gonna waste
a dog for the sake i mean you know good
for them good for them well well maybe
they thought it would be too hard it's
like well obviously we can't like throw
a [ __ ] dog against the wall and
you know what i mean maybe they just
thought it was too much trouble people
are in there saying that they haven't
seen this movie now they're gonna watch
it and people saying that i saw this
movie it was [ __ ] hilar it was
[ __ ] good i didn't expect to be good
yeah it's a good movie it's free on
youtube and it's good i mean it's very
very decent and like i said if you're
into a haunting and if you're into like
real poltergeist [ __ ] this is supposedly
i don't know if this story is true or
not but it rings true with me or at
least parts of it do the way it builds
up
kind of like old guy's case and i mean
the horns were involved and they
exaggerate [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
so it's just kind of like and the thing
about it too i kind of like that it goes
into because okay so
what happens this started in it happened
in pennsylvania in west pittston and you
have jack and janet's mural they got a
bunch of kids i think they have four
daughters they ended up having four
daughters i think they had two and then
they moved into the house and they had
two later on so it starts in 1974 they
moved into
it's like a duplex like i've seen
pictures of the real house
it's like a duplex and his like jack's
mom and dad who were somewhat elderly
like lived in one side of the duplex and
then their family lived in the other
side of the duplex
and
like at first it was just kind of like
little [ __ ] right it was just kind of
like i think the first thing that
happened was
um she kept hearing voices but then
uh he was working on the pipes or some
[ __ ] like that and he was like had a
hammer and then like he turned around
and the hammer was gone and he's like
what the [ __ ] like where did it go
asking around and then like later on he
comes and then it's back like in the
same exact place again so it was like
little [ __ ] like that
but apparently this happened like over
essentially like a 15-year period really
yeah so it started like kind of because
i think like the last thing like when
they moved out i think it was like 89 or
something like that but
um but yeah so one of the first things
like she kept hearing what she thought
was her mother-in-law like calling her
name and then she was like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about i wasn't calling
you and then
the mother-in-law
started hearing what she thought was
jack and janet in the other house like
having these horrible fights and just
like swearing up and these are like
super super religious like catholic
people so they were just she's like i've
never heard such scandalous language
like that kind of thing she's like you
got and she's like bro like dude my wife
my husband is even home right now and
like nobody is swearing so you know who
knows what she heard she never did keep
your yeah well that's the thing it's um
supposedly and like whoever was in that
in jack and janet's side of the house
janet was over there by herself and she
didn't hear anything so when she went
over there and talked to her mom and her
mom and her mom-in-law was like all
huffy like i've never heard such
language coming out of your mouth well
she's like i wasn't saying anything like
nobody's there but me and so there was
this whole thing and so for a long time
like her and her mother-in-law were like
upset but then
it started getting to a point where
they said they like all kind of like bad
smells in their house like the light
over the kitchen table like busted and
like cut one of their kids uh one of
their kids got like thrown
off the balcony like off the or down the
stairs or something like levitated out
of bed and like throwing down the stairs
they um janet said she kept seeing like
a like a apparition she said it wasn't
like a person it looked like just like a
black
foggy
thing that sort of like moved around and
it would go through the walls like
between her their house and their
parents house yeah and then the mom saw
it too and it's funny because just like
in every episode of haunting um the
husband didn't see anything yeah he
didn't believe her and he's just like
years been watching too many scary
movies i'm like yeah that that explains
me seeing like all this [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] yeah well because and he was kind
of a dick at the beginning you know what
i mean where he was just
well and even after the mother-in-law
saw it too and they were kind of like
there and like the men were just like
silly women they just they don't know
anything and there's like no seriously
we both saw it it was like really scary
[ __ ] and they're just like they just
weren't they weren't having it you know
what i mean
and you said if it was you like if i
came up to you and said hey i saw this
that and the other thing i'd be
interested you'd be into well and plus
you would ask a lot more questions you
wouldn't be dismissive like that i mean
even if you thought that i was losing my
mind or i had a brain tumor or something
like that
like you would ask more questions to try
to establish like what exactly was going
on right he didn't really see me just
like oh shut up you know i mean he
didn't say that but he was just like
really really dismissive about the whole
[ __ ] at least that's what it was
portrayed in the movie yeah i don't know
if he's really in real life but in the
movie like i said that's always like
more conflict and you like that in your
movies so and but then like the one
night the one thing that convinces him
right is that they're laying in bed and
she's laying by on her pillow and then
she hears like that voice like
whispering like it's coming out of her
like through the pillow yeah which holy
crap i would [ __ ] myself if that
happened yeah but um
but you know so she like jumps up like
what the [ __ ] like somebody's whispering
and he's like would you stop it's like
what is this all about that she's like
no just put your head right there and
listen and he does and he doesn't hear
anything for a second
but then he hears it and then he's like
what the [ __ ] and she's like i [ __ ]
told you i told you and then it touches
her leg and he and she's like put your
leg here on top of my leg and watch and
it touched his like he's oh yeah i feel
it
and that's that's what convinced him did
he even ever say that he was sorry for
being like such a douche or like no no
not in the movie not in the movie right
now
she was like
he's a man i have a challenge
he's a man you know you know and i don't
and at that point it had been going on
for like years and she thought that she
was losing her mind because nobody saw
the [ __ ] but her so that's the weird
thing that kind of
that that part of it it was years that's
how long it was
yeah we know that okay yeah well because
like i said when they first moved there
yeah um that was 1974 and like little
[ __ ] happened and then she had twin
girls
and then later on like you see stuff
happening but like the kids are like
growing up it's kind of strange because
at mammoth mountain and [ __ ] me and
red and lois were convinced within hours
it didn't take years within hours we
were all in on the same page of music
so you know i mean it's a different case
maybe the phenomenon manifests itself
differently
different levels of [ __ ] strength but
i think it's strange that people would
be on different pages of music for years
you know what i mean well the thing
about it too was that she was home all
the time because i guess she was like a
homemaker and the kids were at school
and he was at work
so i guess she was bi but i don't know
like i said i don't know
or maybe he there were things going on
when he was home and that he was just
wrote it off like i said he had the
hammer thing happened to him and he was
just kind of like oh whatever i must
have just
you know that's not supernatural which
yeah that's plausible deniability it
could not be that but
that's i i don't know danny says that
the on-screen television version was the
best portrayal of ed lorraine that he's
seen maybe it's funny because the woman
playing
uh lorraine warren here diane baker i
was like hey that's what's her name from
silence of the lambs yeah that played
the kidnapped girl's mom
i recognized her immediately and silence
of the lambs came out the same year as
this movie which is crazy um zach
included their girlfriend though their
16 year old girlfriend that'd have been
a lot better
well yeah
they never put that in the movies they
never put that they didn't see that in
the conjuring but yeah they had that
they had like a 16 or 17 year old
girlfriend that [ __ ] lived with them
yeah you know some weird [ __ ]
zach says i might be misremembering but
doesn't the dad and this kind of look
like a skinny or dr phil he does
actually yeah that's um jeffrey de mon
he has been in a [ __ ] ton of stuff he
was uh dale of the walking dead remember
that like the first couple seasons he
was in the hitcher he was in the 1988
version of the blob he was in um
shawshank redemption he was in
hollywoodland
the mist he's been in a [ __ ] ton of
stuff
but yeah so i just thought that was
funny that um i can't remember like the
guy playing ed
they're not in it a lot the warrens
they kind of like because what ended up
happening was they had all this crazy
[ __ ] happen mostly it was her seeing
stuff and then [ __ ] started happening
like i said when that whole thing
happened with like the whispering pillow
and the hand on the thigh and all that
like then suddenly they're all on the
same page and then like [ __ ] started
going crazy like then they had like
[ __ ] tv coming on all bright and like
[ __ ] drawers going in and out and
like lights breaking and all kind of
crap like that and
they i think they went to the church
first right
and the the priest came
over or bishop or not the bishop
whatever the [ __ ] um and he came over
for dinner
and he he's like oh well you know i'm
sure that's nothing and it's like you
guys just need to come to marriage
counseling that's usually all this stuff
is
and then he's like well i'll just bless
the house like just to get them to shut
up and then like he goes upstairs and
kind of has like a priest from
amityville moment like nobody says get
out or anything like that but it freaks
him out he it freaks him out and he gets
all like he doesn't feel very well and
[ __ ] like that that's one of the things
i did like about this tv this tv movie
is that it was detailed
yeah it was detailed they mentioned
little details in it
that a lot of other [ __ ] shows would
have probably passed on like well that's
not that scary we're not gonna talk
about
you know what you heard in your [ __ ]
pillow and we're not going to talk about
this
we're not going to leave this you know
we want it it's got to be big you know
so it's
the way it's written and what it shows
is very kind of academic it's
very much kind of like something jamie
would write [ __ ] and and steve
merrill would write together during one
you know case that they covered or
something like that so i liked it you
know it's almost kind of like like i
said it's almost like a reenactment yeah
like like like a haunting it right it's
like almost like documented it has like
a little bit of like kind of a
documentary feel to it yeah it has like
a narration because like i said it
covers a long time period um and there's
times too where like they after all this
[ __ ] was happening and no one was really
believing them and they were like well
we need to get the [ __ ] out of this
house for a few days they decide to go
camping and then they see like the weird
like black
shadowy thing has like followed them
because i guess the ghost wanted to go
camping too but like when the warrens
finally come because like i said they
they have the priest
and he comes and he's just kind of like
yeah i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
and they're like well can you at least
like get somebody to like exercise the
[ __ ] or whatever y'all do and he's like
yeah i can't do that so i can't get
involved so he just like puts the [ __ ]
out
and so then like she goes and does all
this research and then she goes and
finds the warrens i guess she went i
don't know if this is what really
happened but this is what was in the
book where she went to a lecture that
they were giving locally and asked them
to come help her so they came to the
house and so lorraine like walks around
the house and you know how she does like
her psychic thing and so she says that
there's four ghosts in there
and she says that
three of them are like no big or like
not dangerous or anything but then the
other one inevitably is a demon
and the whole demon and maybe this kind
of explains why
at least in the context of the story
that
um that janet was the only one seeing
stuff because the demon was supposedly
like trying to drive a wedge between
everybody so maybe they were just trying
to think oh she's crazy or they're
trying to cause conflict or whatever so
she says okay there's a demon and then
they tried to get like a priest in there
to exercise and they wouldn't do it and
then they get this one priest to come
there and he stays for like two nights
and then he's like yeah i'm out like
nothing happens
and he's like well i did all i could i'm
like so you well you just sat on their
couch for two days and ate food out of
their fridge and like that's all you did
okay good job and uh but nothing
happened while he was there but the
thing about it was that when they were
on the camping trip and the little like
um like black cloudy ghost like followed
them
when they were gone apparently their
neighbors called the cops because they
didn't know that the smurls weren't home
and they said there was like [ __ ]
lights flashing and like [ __ ]
screaming and all this [ __ ] coming out
we thought the whole [ __ ] family was
being murdered in there so they called
the cops and the cops came and like they
went in there and there was no one home
so when the smurl family came home
allegedly like their neighbors came up
and said what the [ __ ] like all the [ __ ]
was going on in the house while you guys
weren't even yelling like we weren't
even here so
yeah so that was kind of all like part
of the story that they that they did but
so what they ended up doing because they
couldn't get the church to help them was
they said well we're gonna go to the
press because maybe if we publicize this
enough it'll shame the church into like
sending somebody to over here to
exercise the [ __ ] right so that's what
they did but then that kind of ended up
biting them in the ass because then they
had like reporters like camping out on
their [ __ ] lawn like for ages and
like then kids would come by and make
fun of everybody and like throw bricks
through their windows and [ __ ] like that
so
and they ended up having to move in the
end and i think after they moved they
don't really go into this in the movie
but i think after they moved um i think
the [ __ ] followed them
like for a little while until they
finally got somebody to come to do an
exorcism or whatever and then supposedly
it stopped
but it supposedly did fall and i don't
know did they bring up in the movie
that they had four daughters a couple of
which were
teenagers so
yeah they brought that up did they bring
that up i thought they had yeah
they showed them
no i mean did they bring up that maybe
that's what was causing yeah nobody
mentioned like poltergeist though they
did
did they yeah because lorraine warren
said to your daughters are just right
just passing puberty which is a good
energy source for these things
and she's talking about poltergeist yeah
but they don't believe in those they
think that yeah yeah she thought it was
well she thought it was three ghosts and
a demon and a demon yeah they're always
gonna say it's demons
but uh a lot of the stuff to me sounded
like poltergeist activity and you got
all those kids probably in the same
house probably under stress
which could cause a poltergeist
manifestations
which are from you know
the unconscious of the mind the id
the dark side
and they can they can uh
imitate
ghostly and demonic phenomena but it's
not
it's not what's doing it it's the
unconscious of those girls subconscious
just like a character in one of your
dreams
i mean you can dream about a really
nasty character that comes after you and
tries to kill you and does all kinds of
stuff
and from your point of view it's an
outside force but it's actually just
another part of your mind imagine if
that had psychic abilities when it came
to say like telekinesis
you know it would impersonate something
out of your dreams and or out of your
nightmares
it would try to do stuff that's what i
believe
at least the poultry guys that we
experienced
at mammoth mountain was that
and back at lois's house
it's just a uh
a dream character
in your waking hours
from your sub from your subconscious or
your unconscious and it has
psychokinesis
that's what made the most sense to me
oh and i forgot to that one of the early
things that happened in this was like
the toaster caught fire when it was
unplugged yeah more poultry guys type
yeah and that's it
i i don't okay here's the thing
from day one whenever we talked about
the warrens i always say the warrens
were charlatans
but we have also right along that right
alongside that said that the warrens
were on some real cases
the warrens did do some real cases
but they weren't what the warrens
thought they were the warrens made a lot
of money off of [ __ ] demonology
they're demonologists
whenever something happens what are they
what are they going to tell you it's a
demon
because that's what they were
if they were parapsychologists they
would tell you something else they were
like no this is rspk
this isn't a demon it's a fake demon
it's doing things like a demon but
that's not what it is that's what they
would say
if you were a parapsychologist so
just because we make fun of the warrants
doesn't mean that we're making fun of
the cases that the warrens were on
the warrens also had a [ __ ] uh
reputation for exaggerating [ __ ] and
blowing [ __ ] a poor purpose because
[ __ ] ed
was a media [ __ ]
i mean he was about the money
and he would do it he would say or do
whatever he had to do to get on [ __ ]
geraldo or just sally jesse and yeah
they made a lot of money off the lecture
circuit yeah and stuff like that right
so that was kind of their main source of
income so if they had a real case that
would say like a level 3 out of 10 oh
man ed was gonna boost that up to a
[ __ ] eight or nine
because it was about
revenue you know
and i think that they would probably
also lie about cases that didn't exist
a case could be a zero and they'll pump
it up to three or four try to make some
money off that too
yeah
but that's just the way they were
yeah i mean you know they were trying to
make a budget trying to make a buck off
of a [ __ ] paranormal phenomena get on
television sell books
some people might say well that's what
you that's what you and jenny are doing
no not really no [ __ ] mammoth
mountain doesn't sell much [ __ ] her
[ __ ] true crime sells [ __ ] way
more than paranormal
you know and
[ __ ]
i just i heard that the math mountain
book that she wrote was based upon what
me and [ __ ] my aunt lois and red told
her
and
that happened a long time ago if we were
gonna if it was something we made up
trying to make money we would have made
that up a long time ago and you guys
have seen those old photos they're in
the book we took pictures of that [ __ ]
back then
okay with your polaroid with a polaroid
polaroid a little [ __ ] smiley face
made out of [ __ ] rolled up towels and
[ __ ] on the bed just ridiculous [ __ ]
you'd never think of anything like that
you know but because we just took
pictures of what it did and it did some
weird [ __ ]
yeah that's i so i kind of feel like i
mean this is probably one of the better
known i guess like haunting or slash
poltergeist cases probably because of
all the raping
yeah um i gotta see this [ __ ] [ __ ] again
it's just kind of like yeah okay so we
got to do this case if we didn't do this
case already i'm gonna i'll look it up i
don't because i can't remember i don't
think we did yeah but
we very well may have like i said
they do geraldo and sally jesse and all
that too i wouldn't mind seeing those
maybe probably i'm gonna have to dig all
that [ __ ] up
okay you know cause there's so much like
ghosty rapey stuff going on in this case
that i confuse it with the other case
which i can't remember right now where
the guy said he got raped by a pig
creature yeah that's not the smurls i
don't think is it i don't know there was
another i think that's a different case
maybe maybe some of the audience might
remember this one
there was one i guess that was this is
before i went into the army
so it must have been around 89.
there were snetakers there you go the
staticurse yeah the snedekers was the
pig wood that's right
the pig rape yeah that was uh
[ __ ] that was actually um
a haunting did a real good almost i
think paranormal witness did one too i
think they both did uh did one i'm not a
hundred percent sure the sneakers were
on the up and up the neighbors didn't
think so and some people i don't know
but some of the some of the programs
about the senators sound very convincing
but then then later then aft then over
the years i've heard other things that
kind of countered what was in those
programs so i don't really know what to
think about it but there was one that i
remembered
before i went into the army
where they were on geraldo rivera
and it was a investigator who was trying
to help a family of women
it's a whole house full of women
and of different ages
and the women kept reporting that
someone was grabbing them in the middle
of the night
they saying lewd things to them out of
them just out of the [ __ ] air when
they were taking a shower when they
[ __ ] didn't have any clothes on
a couple of them and they were like some
of them were like 10 11 12 the girls
that lived in there and some of the
women were you know in their 20s and 30s
and they were all good-looking
women from what i remember been a long
time since i've seen it
that episode
and uh
some people were kind of heckled and i'm
like oh that's not happening and then uh
one of the women who was like in her 20s
says oh no no i woke up in the middle of
the night and saw a shadowy figure at
the foot of the bed on his knees [ __ ]
masturbating
over her yeah and they had some kind of
a [ __ ]
sexual [ __ ] ghost
and
they questioned the investigator and
he's like yeah well i know who it is
you know and this is what you mean who
it is it's based based on the based on
the description that
these women have given me what they're
talking about is the old owner of the
building
you know it's him it was a super perv it
was yeah
yeah it was a guy who died he still and
i think he was like a uh he was an owner
and superintendent superintendent of a
small like uh
apartment complex not really more like
condominiums like three or four
condominiums connected how come [ __ ]
like that get to be ghosts yeah
after all that you have this amazing
thing wow i died and i'm still around i
think i'm just gonna like wander around
and jerk off jerk off
your own girls right and then like uh
do better and they're like
and they're like yeah i know it is based
on based on the uh
uh
the description and he had a history of
sec being a sexual offender that's
if i remember correctly that's what they
just carried that [ __ ] on that [ __ ] off
into the [ __ ] into the afterlife yeah
which at the time
i was young at that time probably 20
19 i was like man that's [ __ ] some
creepy [ __ ] because i'd already seen
poltergeist myself me and lois and red
so it's like to me that was just like
plausible it's like yeah something like
that might happen
dude could die and his pervy ass [ __ ]
floating around
exteriorized like a [ __ ] you know in
the [ __ ] cosmic ghost and [ __ ]
jerking off over women
watching them you know what i mean i
mean it's bad like god damn it like
[ __ ] creepers are bad enough when
they're alive and then like they that
after they're dead they can just go
through the walls and yeah watch you
while you're on the toilet and [ __ ]
having them underage women by the booty
when they're walking by just cupping it
cupping it
abusing it you know i'm talking about
[ __ ] leave it alone that's [ __ ] up
yeah yeah come on but i could see a
demon demonic kind of sick [ __ ]
in the afterlife doing that
i could imagine it
i don't know if it's real i wrote a
short story but you know if any of you
guys remember that i think it was
geraldo rivera i think that was the show
i was never able to find it again i
looked for it but i don't know the name
of the case
yeah i don't remember if like i don't
remember that one specifically i
remember some other i remember some
other cases that were like all women or
like a house full of women but i don't
remember it was either
geraldo or montel
it might have been montel but
i think
i think it was geraldo
although montel didn't have much room to
talk the montel was a pool and hound too
i don't know if you all know that
[ __ ] montel always had two or three
girlfriends at once monta was a [ __ ]
player although i guess back in those
days if you could be a player than that
so it's not like he was going after
anybody under age but they just say my
montel was a big i mean as long as
everybody knew about it everybody and
nobody was yeah i liked my town i liked
my tail i thought that was cool
fellow fella bald man
[Laughter]
yeah right yeah zach says i just tried
looking for that case and found an
article titled mind that ectoplasm a
short popular history of masturbating
ghosts okay so he found it okay well i
don't know he found an article called
that so i'm going to have to go read
that now you realize
yeah
it was the superintendent of like a
condominium my interest he supposedly
died and he's beating off on all the
women
per
perv like was anything coming out was it
ectoplasm no she's just like
from what i remember she just woke up i
mean that's a great saw dude at the foot
of the bed on his [ __ ] knees [ __ ]
just furiously [ __ ] just beating off
and [ __ ] she could hear him [ __ ]
grunting and groaning and then when she
screamed he vanished that's the way i
remember
yeah ghostbuster yeah he was scratching
him
grabbing her it was just a house full of
women it was grabbing her titties and
[ __ ]
molesting them in the [ __ ] bathroom
and [ __ ] now i remember some cases that
they covered on a haunting yeah where
like some ghosts would like grab their
boobs or something yeah like that he was
doing that stuff like that grabbing him
but i don't remember i don't remember
the phone while they were taking a
shower and stuff and [ __ ]
they'd be taking a shower and it would
[ __ ] whisper something into their
ears out of nowhere you know
man that sucks you can't even like you
can't even mase a [ __ ] like that no
he's all invisible [ __ ] perv
and he was like a dude in his 60s and
[ __ ] when he was a court of course he
was 60s [ __ ] creepy old girl
man god damn it
but yeah i mean
oh [ __ ] perv ghost
of ghosts yeah well this this ghost in
this case was a perv too yeah
or demon or whatever the [ __ ] it was
i don't really know like i said they
didn't really go into the
i think
i don't know if all of the girls but i
kind of got the feeling like from the
from the
details about the case that the dad
wasn't the only one that got molested by
the demon that the demon was just zach's
putting putting all this on me it's not
my fault zach
[Laughter]
look i went to the biker bar today i
i've been drinking a little bit there's
only two drinks and then they gave me
some free ones and [ __ ] how many free
ones two free ones there's 17
no
just a bunch of old biker women trying
to get me to go up on a [ __ ] pole and
dance and [ __ ] did you no i went up
there and dropped trout and [ __ ] a
little bit but i didn't pull my
underwear off
[Music]
black of women are funny
[Laughter]
tom's getting objectified yes i said i
said it says stop being sexist and they
start laughing and they're going and
they were like when all these girls take
their tops off for all these [ __ ]
pervy ass man now it's
[Laughter]
i just tried looking for that phrase and
i have to delete my history yeah
i'm not proud i'm gonna look it up yeah
i'm gonna end up on a list somewhere
yeah probably
uh let's see oh they're talking about oh
they that how they wish uh grace
dabrisky had played
uh lorraine warren at some point that
would have been fantastic i still
haven't watched twin peaks the return i
have it i bought it i have all of the
twin peaks one two and three all in one
big box set and i still haven't sat down
to watch it yet because i suck
apparently i just haven't had time to do
it danny says honey in connecticut case
is scary as [ __ ] oh haunted funeral home
yeah yeah yeah
that first couple seasons of a haunting
jenny bought me ever pretty much every
[ __ ] i think i bought you every like
one through seven
there's more of them out there yeah
um but the thing is is that that i gotta
i gotta go back and see what we have and
see how much they want
for other seasons because that that
series got purchased by other companies
and kind of went downhill over time it
did um but the first
the first [ __ ] like six or seven
seasons are really good on the haunting
the first two are the best
and [ __ ] haunting in connecticut is
one of them
um and the haunting is summer win that
was a good one too i think that was
episode one wasn't it haunting a summer
win uh no i think a haunting in georgia
was the first one or a haunting in
connecticut i can't remember because i
think that was the pilot right the one
about mr gordy like
georgia yeah that was good too that
might have been one of the first ones
summer when hunting and hunting in
connecticut were some of the two
episodes two of the best yeah i think
well what i did i think i bought you the
first
four seasons or five seasons like in one
box and one box yeah because they used
to sell them on dvd like on box set and
then and then they started selling them
like separately so i think i bought you
like seven or six and seven maybe
and then put those things on they're
very relaxing to watch yeah we used to
just we've seen like the the first few
seasons like lots and lots of times i'm
gonna look up and see what's out there
maybe i'll get another season of that
[ __ ] and see if it's any good because
everyone that i own is good
every season we have is good i don't
know what the other seasons are like
though
you might be able to well you might be
able to watch them on streaming too
because i think that some one of the
streaming services has them i think for
free maybe for free maybe see them for
free maybe first something like that and
see if they're any good yeah danny
rowling says the later episodes seemed
made up to me yeah i kind of they got
more and more like outlander outlandish
well i think it was because probably
they were running out of cases so they
had to [ __ ] dig so they had to like
really dig deep and you were kind of
getting across people was like hey i got
a story you know what i mean so i maybe
think about that i mean they went going
like yeah which covens and wherewithal
like the first five episodes the first
five seasons or five or six seasons were
good real good
yeah i liked him a lot and you know like
i said i think i put it in the poll a
couple times but it hasn't won yet but i
think we should do like another yeah we
should go back to us we should go back
to doing we haven't done one in a long
time i can't remember did we do that one
uh that was called the diabolical
did we should do the dive
that's one little kid right
i think we did diabolical i can't
remember if we did this one with little
kids just [ __ ] with man right
demon child demon child we did that we
did demonstrate because that's one of my
favorite episodes because that [ __ ]
kid man that i could did we ever do do
we ever do the one with my friend in it
from [ __ ] uh delta yeah we did that
yeah hunting in florida yeah yeah we've
totally done that one okay um and we did
the bobby mackey one bobby mackie yeah
we did cause i wanted the thing about it
is that sometimes if they don't give you
enough details or if they've changed the
names uh or the stuff that happened
enough in the episode you can't find any
other
sources yeah for that haunting so it's
like you kind of have to pick ones that
are slightly better known cases yeah you
know like the snedeker case or whatever
because
otherwise you're not going to be able to
like find any other
reason another good one was the
apartment
remember that one yeah
another good one was the one where the
guy had the [ __ ] demon in the hole
behind the dam
now we did do a show on that one because
i'm pretty sure that that was the one
that came up well because that was the
one with the with the guy that murdered
the guy and then tried to say he was
possessed by a demon like yeah that's
right the devil maybe do it because yeah
because that actually like ended up with
a real murder and he was trying to like
argue demon possession right you know
what i mean there's there's a bunch on
the haunting series that we could do
yeah i know which is the one that i
remembered was the diabolical because
you always used to yes
because you always used to do that all
the time another good one was the uh was
the i think we did a show on it though
the family that went to uh taiwan or
thailand yeah yeah i don't know if we
did that one i think we did i think we
did yeah hungry ghosts hungry ghosts
yeah yeah yeah we did do we do hungry
ghosts that was a good one all like all
the big main episodes that i could find
other sources on i think we've done but
so we need to go down to like the next
tier because sometimes the the titles of
the episodes
are
like kind of generic so it's like
sometimes when i go through the episode
list i'm just like wait which one was
that again but then like when i watch it
i remember if y'all don't know what
we're talking about
in the early shows we would do reviews
of a series that was out a long time ago
called a haunting
and the first five or six seasons of a
haunting is really good if you guys have
never seen them go see it
probably get them for free or through
hulu or whatever i'm pretty sure they
might be on a streaming service if
you've never seen a haunting series
maybe they're on two beers start with
start with season one and go through a
haunting they're they were really well
done they were even better than a lot of
horror movies they were better than like
some of the old classic horror movies
like like uh like amityville horror they
were better than that
um
and they were television series
and i liked the amityville
yeah i did too but uh you what you put
you put the movie ambivale horror up
against some of those haunting episodes
no the haunting episodes were better
yeah some of them were actually like
really creepy yeah
yeah and based on cases that evidently
were
things that happened
some of them i think might be a little
bit more credible than others depends on
depends on the actual case
but it doesn't matter it's just it was
just a company trying to bring you that
case
in an entertaining format yeah sometimes
you can look in deeper into that case
and it's like well it didn't exactly
happen that way
uh they never really show you the
evidence that they had like they'll talk
about photos that were taken and they'll
show you a fake photo of what was taking
it not the real photo look at the real
photo you go yeah it's probably a piece
of dust in front of the [ __ ] flash
yeah that was one thing that was
slightly better about paranormal witness
when it came out was that they actually
use like the real the real evidence like
real photographs and real footage if
they had it i mean they did you know
reenactment too but but when it came to
pure entertainment you wanted to watch a
haunting
the haunting i just i don't know i just
better entertain i just really kind of
liked the theme song and just the whole
vibe of it it was just like really i
think those started like in 2006 i think
it was 2006 2017
and it was on like for a long for a long
time and then all these other channels
tried to copy it like [ __ ]
ghost pet or [ __ ]
i'd watch you guys
because the animal channel had to have
their own [ __ ] ghost stories and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that
where they're barely shoehorning the dog
into the story to justify its existence
on [ __ ] and the title of the show
didn't even have anything to do with
animals it was just called like
yeah yeah it was just talking dogs of
the ghost pet
like what and then you're like wait a
minute we're talking about amityville
yeah they had a dog don't you remember
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and the dog one
time like barks at a corner that's right
that's right
uh i would say you want to watch
paranormal witness or a haunting those
two series were the best
in recent history danny rowling says the
lake shore club episode was good yeah
yeah i remember that one too it sounds
familiar lake shore and then oh danny
rowling said oh i didn't know this
actually he said there's a made for tv
movie on the devil made me do it case i
don't know um yeah yeah that we were
just talking about with the well the
hell thing yeah uh starring kevin bacon
from the 80s also free on youtube what's
the name of it
i don't know i don't know yeah tell us
the name we'll check it out i'll look it
up because yeah because like i said that
was a case that they talked about on a
haunting and but that was a real like
the warrens were involved in that one
too i think but that was supposedly yeah
like the guy like murdered a dude like
later on and said oh like he was trying
to argue demon possession like to wang
his way out of it yeah but is it
reconnecting
it still says green but i got the little
obs thing that said yeah it's just
connected
okay it says it reconnected okay is it
all right i don't know i was shutting it
down so i don't know okay probably okay
i think it's okay i think we had a
little blip there for a second but yeah
so we're gonna wrap it up thanks for
dropping by today thanks for the
recommendation for this movie because i
don't think we would have watched it
otherwise like i said i've seen it
before but it was a long time ago and
i'd kind of forgotten about it so
tomorrow is wednesday and that's going
to be our main show it's going to be
episode 303 and we're going to be
talking about
mata hari which i think will be like a
really interesting show she was a very
interesting
woman uh you know kind of maybe a spy in
the
during world war one or maybe not we'll
see how that goes but uh yeah so we'll
see you guys again tomorrow evening
thanks for dropping by have a good rest
of your day
see you later bye